what about I'm sorry one of the things
that I like about this show is that you
it's based on real conversations yeah
that you've had you use conversations
with your daughter I do show I do like
how old is your daughter my daughter is
eight in in real life right and then on
the show she's a couple years younger
but yeah even in the pilot we recreated
a scene where my daughter was very
concerned of how babies come out of your
body which is a common thing for
children be curious about very common we
were in a Baja Fresh at the time oh
that's usually not where this
conversation should happen no no and it
was in a loud voice I would say and she
was to be clear not concerned she
doesn't not concerned of how babies are
made how does it baby get in there right
there was just a concern of is this
gonna happen to me and it's been gonna
be next Tuesday right like what you know
what I mean like what's what it was
having so I I sort of was I'm that mom
like I'm just gonna kind of tell it like
it is but appropriate for firms like
your body's magical and when it knows
that the baby's ready to come out the
whole just gets really really really big
and then the baby shoots out right what
a lovely description by the way it's a
miracle yeah all gets really big and the
baby she yeah yeah well her takeaway
from that was pause so you have a huge
vagina which reigned across Baja Fresh
oh she said that probably during an
unusually quiet moment in the Baja Fresh
yeah yeah yeah yeah where you know my
husband was just still in his burrito
just not even looking up just like this
isn't happening I'm like I look up right
um I felt the need to address the people
near me and let them know everything is
fine yeah no complaints from husband Oh
from Andy
are you it that has never given me any
reason to complain about your vagina
true in the history of our relations
matter
never
you